what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today we are
going to be talking about
um a model says drake put hot sauce in
condoms to kill sperm and not get
trapped before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it send any video requests to
my instagram just dot pearly things
that's just dot pearly things
and
guys if you have
watched if you've watched more than
three of my videos and you have not
subscribed we have beef
help a girl out
i'm struggling like god damn okay okay
anyways i'm gonna continue
so
model says drake put hot sauce in
condoms to kill sperm and not get
trapped a model may be filing a lawsuit
against drake after things got a little
too spicy in the bedroom while chatting
with
too much hot tea the instagram model
whose name wasn't revealed said that she
had consensual intercourse with drake a
few weeks ago
and she tried to trap him
when things went left after they
finished having intercourse oh can i say
that on youtube
oh no
drake went into the bathroom
and disposed of a condom the model then
went into the bathroom and tried to
impregnate herself with the sperm while
doing this she screamed feeling a
burning sensation the sixth god told her
that he put hot sauce in the condom to
kill the sperm
okay number one let's talk about number
one ladies what are we doing here
why on earth would this be a good idea
okay two that can't work
does it
that's just that just seems strange
three
okay
all of this energy and time you guys are
putting into chasing after a celebrity
and chasing after that one in a million
chance that you out of the million girls
that he sleeps with is going to get
pregnant if you put that time and energy
into being a good wife
trying to get a guy of value i i want to
i'm not you know i'm not kevin samuels
here i'm not going to give you life
advice
i think that might be a better use of
your time um that should be illegal that
really should be illegal
um in his latest post
drake didn't confirm or deny the story
but he seems to have responded you can
have your 15 minutes of fame i'll take
the under 23 hours and 45 minutes he
captioned to
us he captioned a set of two photos the
model isn't the only one looking for
some cons compensation after the
astroworld tragedy drake along with
travis scott were hit with a dozen
lawsuits over the music festival which
led to 10 deaths including a 14 and a 9
year old okay that's something else um
okay
ladies ladies
especially if you're an ig model that
means you're hot
do you know how many options you have
just by being hot you know how many guys
will overlook your crazy
if you are hot enough now look i'm not
saying drake will he certainly won't
apparently
but
if that was me i would never in a
million years do something like that but
if i was to do something that crazy i
would not scream or get mad
you just pretend you did nothing because
that is insane
that that is literally insane
i want to see if there's any
drake's clever response so he had a
response to this
oh it was the instagram post right he
had like hot sauce and
i just wanted to know what model was it
anyone anyone tell you
well okay
this is this is my final thoughts you
can't expect anything if you're sleeping
with a celebrity if if it's especially
i'm not even just an a-list celebrity
like an a i don't know if there's a such
thing as an a a-list celebrity but if
there is it would be drake like a double
a like he is so famous that he you're
never going to see him again the second
thing
is
i can't imagine that's that effective i
know your odds of getting pregnant in
general
are low like if you're trying to get
pregnant
like
one it has to be the days of the month
you're ovulating and two
even if you are ovulating
i don't know what your odds are but i
can't imagine they're great so you think
you're getting pregnant from the one
time you hook up with drake
by putting his stuff up you oh
that's so gross
okay well
um yeah she's crazy sorry
um okay before i end this video don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell
i will talk to you guys next time